a staple of daytime TV since 1972
The Price is Right is a longest-running
game show in American television history
hosted by the iconic Bob Barker for more
than 35 years and 7,000 episodes is
continued to thrive after Barker's
retirement under the stewardship of
comedian drew Carey but how much do you
actually know about this television
institution here's a look at the untold
truth of the prices right let's make a
deal when the price is right debuted in
1972 it was actually titled the new
prices right a title it kept for a
little under a year that's because it
was loosely based on a primetime game
show that had aired as early as 1956
where contestants went small prizes by
guessing how much household items cost
but by the 70s the original concept was
deemed too boring
instead CBS told producer mark Goodson
that if he wanted to revive the prices
right he should look at their hit game
show let's make a deal for inspiration
he did borrowing a slew of gimmicks like
pulling people out of the studio
audience to be contestants using lights
and sound effects to get the crowd hyped
and having the contestants play lots of
different little games by the cultural
phenomenon cliffhangers there's no way
that microwave class more than 300 bucks
stop here
don't call us at that fat tourists she
doesn't know how much a microwave crash
the best of the best every game show us
a different process for contestant
selection jeopardy for example is quite
rigorous putting prospective guests
through multiple written tests an
interview and a live test version of the
game against other hopefuls The Price is
Right is far more immediate on taping
days contestants / studio audience
members line up for as long as four
hours outside Bob Barker studio at CBS
television city in Los Angeles then ten
at a time they're herded in front of a
producer who asks them each one question
where they've got to show off a
sparkling personality and lots of energy
only about 100 people also get pig to
sit in the studio audience and the lucky
contestants find out they've been
selected when the announcer calls their
name
showcase showdown showdown in 2008 a
huge priceless right fan named Terry
nice was picked to come on down to
contestants row he made it all the way
to the showcase showdown where he did
something that nobody in the show's
history had done before or since he
guessed the exact price of his prize
package taping stopped for almost an
hour as the producers and host Drew
Carey was sure nice had cheated but he
hadn't instead he had studied the show
for years and realized that many prizes
were repeated so he memorized the prices
of all the prizes and added them up in
his head during his appearance as a
result he went both showcase prize pools
and the price has right changed their
price structure to include more variance
in price structure but twenty three
thousand seven hundred forty three
dollars extra retail price twenty three
thousand seven hundred forty three
dollars you got a red on the nose
replacing a legend finding a replacement
for Barca wasn't easy the search was so
difficult in fact that he even offered
to delay his retirement if a new host
couldn't be found in time numerous stars
secretly recorded mark episodes as hosts
including George Hamilton Ian ziering
Mario Lopez John O'Hurley
Antiques Roadshow host Mark Wahlberg and
former double dare host to mark summers
summers was Bob Barker's first choice as
replacements but after CBS chairman les
Moonves saw Kerry hosting the primetime
gameshow power of 10 he offered Carrie
the gig too bad Adam Sandler didn't
audition the price is wrong [ __ ] a
brand new car as Benjamin Franklin once
famously said only two things in life
are certain Plinko and taxes and
California takes her game show taxes
very seriously they actually treat
gameshow winnings as income and
contestants are required to pay taxes on
the spot before they can take their
prizes home luckily many contestants
also win money on the show in addition
to prizes so it's common for them to pay
taxes using their prize money and
there's a bunch of red tape around the
brand-new car two winners don't drive
home with their sweet ride instead that
the show sends them to a local
dealership to coordinate the livery of
the vehicle
dealership near the contestants home
assuming they have already paid all
those taxes and registration fees first
it's your brand-new